yeah hello and welcome to this video I'm
trying something funny which probably
just something that probably does not
work but I try something I'm trying to
play a sim you'll hear just
spontaneously six six boards and it's
ten plus ten time control this is
probably going to be completely bonkers
but I'm trying it so let's see it should
be quick and it's it's tough to actually
do commentary because you have to move
move move
okay so me for you five some would be
six surprising choice an open Sicilian
here and another French yeah here night
xe5 is good and we have another exchange
French I'm quite happy with the exchange
French I'm currently studying this a
little bit and I think that black has
some small issues to solve some here we
take that's the night off really funny
the boards are flashing okay so it
should be three covering a form I have
to see six so sorry resigned that's not
good why what do you resign okay age
five okay here Bishop g5 should be a
good move King of eight wow that's a
weird move okay let's go age three yeah
we'll take g7 for sure
so some wacky games but I just Castle
and curious night let's go rookie one
centralized it seems that it's not my
move and they are the board so age five
hereby MDL nine thousand yeah I think I
would like to play c4 to pry open this
position also 95 or Bishop g5 makes
sense Bishop g5 probably
is a good good move okay curious night
has played g5 it's the highest rated for
opponent mm yeah I wonder if he/she five
is right
g4 I don't mind that much I can also
insert something like this okay II five
here so I think taking here must be okay
okay g6 by mvl 9000 it seems that he
wants to play King g7 so I go here to
have knight c6 so I provoked a six in
this position so black here has hard
time not to cancel no okay I go here
with d5 yeah I can take him he's six is
hanging curious night responded if I've
almost instantaneously
so I'm regrouping this now 95 years kind
of obvious checking the Queen and TNI g6
on my ideas to put the night on to e3
here at 86 so I think we're down to only
three hmm I don't know can I can I
accept more players said possible only
get two wins him yeah it's not not quite
working other thought okay
no how do I get back into the symbiote
itself look here here here okay so
castles again Knight f5 I guess looks
good and Knight f4 here by the curious
night there is a curious night but let's
remove my Knight to f5 okay so rook F
893 threatening rook takes is 7 so he
went back to c8 with his bishop hmm yeah
I can
[Music]
you play 9f5 mmm
and trying to take on f4 this is not bad
I mean if he takes it I get the
Foursquare okay so here what what's the
deal hmm can I somehow get to g6 to the
g6 pawn maybe just continue to develop a
simple okay he is I think he g3 is in
order
and here g6 I will talk back to e3 I
guess and here he went back to g6 hmm
okay how do you how do you open this up
the night will come to f6 this is pretty
clear
maybe this to have c4 later
nightly form here but why does that work
I can check it several now I click here
and take yourself okay here h3 is the
main news and b5 played by the curious
night unite takes b5 is not entirely
ridiculous a little bit but not entirely
okay I'm trying to go for the c6 square
in this game maybe this is just just
nice for me just take him two pawns up
and a good position okay so here I'm out
for this and later c4 pry open the
position on the on the queenside so
couple of normal positions with early
positions Here I am
this is not so bad for black quite
surprisingly okay I take here knight c6
hmm
96 immediately is not great if I check
here and then 96 yeah it's not clear if
that helps
really ok let's try to pry open the
queenside a 5 here by Bab desert not
sure about the smooth so ok Bishop d7
plate so I check here and this country
chick on d3 probably I don't want that I
mean any position any opening of the
position should be helpful so here okay
so 94 here hmm okay yeah I need I need
the rook yeah that was to be expected I
was thinking here for later knight c6
okay isn't Bishop g6 winning he and
associate should when hopes true p6
coming okay so here 96 can also check
here check on a sec so this is good
Bishop takes Bishop a6 that that seems
to be the point here so let's go Bishop
g5 yeah he I can actually take a six if
I like Bishop takes check and take a six
knight c6 mm 96 doesn't here on Friday
okay let's take it when Bishop h6 yeah
that's where that splat sir okay what
he's doing is totally fine he's free age
five should be five five maybe I
shouldn't take maybe I shouldn't take
him okay so here oh oh that's a funny
move and I knew I did not see at all
okay I have not before but I all looked
at c8 is unprotected so it's casual hmm
not not rated doing such a similar with
rated is a kind of kind of tough okay so
let's go here keep everything covered
actually head on the crop him so context
keeping the spin alive okay and here I
can now go over to f5 with this with the
night he has the pawn and the e5 pawn
stopped at the moment that's not easy to
get it get it moving
I'm not sure about all this maybe just
dismiss him and keep it close okay here
I can check on f6 but I just wanted to
keep everything centralized okay so here
can I somehow get before in maybe with
this and later before yeah but yeah
am I not winning this pawn there Bishop
takes rook takes Queen d5 136 might not
win the pawn hmm it's a bit of a shame
as I'm playing for this idea the whole
time we came let's do a strengthening
this would be five it's not easy to get
before the foreign maybe this Queen c1
with tempo and then before that could be
a good one maybe I should have taken the
other look actually now that I think of
it I go here he's gonna cook see for him
hmm interesting
maybe this one that's a double attack
the rook end is seven g5 like it takes
only 17 g5 is somewhat hanging I mean
not not sure that I ever wanted oh I
know it gives me the book I'm taking
this maybe it was a sacrifice but I
don't think so immediately immediately
entering now
oh yeah and winning everything we can't
have a black plate very quickly so Otto
switch so I mean it's nowhere my move
like him yeah I'm not sure maybe the
simulus not a bad idea in general but I
should probably announce it before and
do it a little bit with the longer time
control yeah it's it's generally
speaking and I think an option but
probably has to be done a bit
differently
Queen age form by I am determined now
he's playing this in a very very well I
was most dashing out quick moves but now
if I was hanging somewhat somewhat
there's still Knight f6 as a trick zone
it's not immediately attacked
difficult staking a long time 94 queenie
for Queenie for Knight f6 Knight takes
d4 wins apiece so it is currently
protected he might play the king a king
g7 or so but I have 94 then ok so c6
hereby be a B but now I can't play again
and this must be a pretty decent ending
I just wonder way I put this maybe here
rook see to 94 or 95 I have a clearly
the better pawn structure in this game
really a lot better the structure c6
weak f5 weak
rook c2 is a good move let's say rook e8
yeah I can just play Roxy - even though
you can certainly argue that I should
just move the move the night
okay so b5 played by I am determined
it's so covering c4 which was an
important idea from United 0 okay so
still this is attacked
yeah just ninety seven to trade some
stuff yeah let's play good job by
determined ninety-seven probably okay
o-obviously
looks it to him just cover be to prepare
be three cover e to it that's a very
sensible move okay yeah no wait wait
wait wait wait
wondering about Bishop twenty-five
but it's so better I can't just take it
on sistex okay so here I'm now only now
I'm understanding that if I take you can
take with the F pawn which is which is
something I should have spotted I can I
can go in with the other night but then
even something like windy eight is going
to be a problem
hmm Jim I don't want to check on on e6
he takes with the f1 I should have seen
that okay I'm just going back pretty bad
okay here Knight f5 is good I think as
Bishop e5 drops d5 and 93 is also on
yeah I'm ahead on the clock even so 93
now is interesting a DM trying to
provoke d4 which would be extremely
helpful rook d6 I can take c5 whoop the
age maybe he has to play yeah look the
8th looks like it should be plated and
then that's not not that fantastic for
me actually I am ok with nothing more
Oh interesting and check here would be
true chick that doesn't help all that
much okay I camera King g7 yeah yeah
this is just not good yeah never was 97
and then going back of course didn't
help
and now e4 is attacked I mean maybe I
have to go back but it looks completely
idiotic iam
he's attacking me for just what it is
okay yeah let's go here a form okay
can't go to f3 I'm sure that it's just
much but that's improved a little bit
okay have to take with the C pawn I've
got two knights against two bishops
which is usually not good I mean I have
a somewhat decent control here over over
things
look before plates whoo
it's hard to do much generally it just
doubles this 23 and he takes on
different no maybe h5 okay so g3 and now
ignite at five if you play special aged
six black captured and now here is there
any way forward probably not so easy if
I go night d1 trying to regroup right if
I play d4 then it looks a bit it looks
bad but a knight on c3 would help
actually a little bit
hmm anyway this may be activating huh
poor tough I have to do something so
clean back to the H I can't do this now
bring the knight back yeah here I was
thinking just troop T 1 then I have 5
next
it's really really tough to make any
headway King aged 80 in this game so so
anyway a form attack this let's do it
let's drive so this is covering d4 so
maybe I can regroup this a little bit
okay now maybe the edge file is actually
something
oops didn't think about this at all
Wow no didn't have this on the Raider
and rook f4 is a big threat Wow okay we
need five yeah here I thought before
would be good it takes at Knight b6
13 seconds here by black for black okay
so he I'm sure he's got d3 Scott III
whom
okay this one d3 check hmm all a bit
shaky
their time is not a problem I have
enough time to get into this and then
yeah the other game the other game is
critical I think I might be okay there
oh no that that will be the end of this
ok so just one game left why I'm ahead
on the clock which is good okay here I
have to check first no alternative and
now I mean he's close to being
checkmated but I don't see how exactly I
could deliver a final blow
originally I was just thinking rooty two
words maybe I have something else
something like King G 3 F 4 double on H
Farouk h6 is made but that takes a while
important SES look b8 now
really look F what are you trying to do
to me here yeah that's a threat
absolutely okay I can check but it
doesn't lead I ever draw em but night H
we're looking something and somehow I
have this impression that I'm not
getting things here
can take 53 to continue that's not
really great
and looking for is a really really big
threat
can check on each boy still has that
friggin check
I don't see anything to be honest
nothing that makes any sense
I mean I can draw of course which ok say
a way to win it always looks bad I have
there's just one there's no square for
blacks King look one the two words not
doing anything you can take I can take
these six and try to play this ending
somehow it doesn't doesn't really need
much I mean I'm a pawn down its what
what's what's going on so I can check it
on IG too which is kind of continuing
everything but that is playing for a
loss more than anything else Jim I don't
want to draw it on okay let's do this
it's probably terrible
just covers a for group t5 is an idea
but you can play something like Bishop
e5 and it's totally ok there's more more
than a gamble than anything else ok so
take him
and yeah that was a really really weird
decision to continue it is just bad yeah
okay so if I go here maybe just d4 comes
and I came probably just going back to
f5
it's still not easy for me to play for
win of course with this precarious when
that's made okay so I had six wins at
the end there was tough by the way there
was one game that was resigned early on
which is understandable that it was
resigned because it is winning funny
motif however is that I had this on the
board once he said this is winning
that's a funny funny move somehow yeah
we see that black cannot take the bishop
as this is losing the rook in the corner
and I think students the Queen but I'm
threatening to take here and play Bishop
g7 and this is a totally over so that
was not an premature resignation at all
yes Antero here resigned probably didn't
want to be in the summer in the first
place yeah and then we had a couple of
tough games where they have the same
yeah that was here that wasn't necessary
at all but if t4 already was losing
interestingly enough I mean here is
there when what is to win with h7 ah
threatening mate yeah maybe maybe I
would have found that that's not it's
not totally out of this world maybe
so yeah what else did we have it this
was a really tough game and I played
badly
yeah maybe here Bishop takes f6 isn't
actually that grade it looks a lot um
ultimately there is this line age 3e 592
h5 Bishop g5 which is of course okay for
white but somehow yeah maybe maybe this
is not so bad the way it turned out
black had equalized 97 was was stupid
Nexus 7 was stupid I didn't really
realize that if I take him only 60 will
just hit with the F porn and of course
it takes with the F porn but I simply
didn't have it on the radar and now this
looks bad and my queen doesn't have a
good screen and I don't know it's
probably not so terrible according to
the engine but it's so not great
yeah Knight f1 yeah I was thinking
actually this is hanging so c3 I thought
I thought you would just take I got
Queen f6 okay oh yeah six and 90s
probably g3m okay that was bad then okay
nine everyone giving blacks the
advantage f5 given by the comp em there
that is very logical given that I'm
going back and forth here with my my
knight simple this this was also
probably good but I think he played a
little bit just to maybe too
conservative flame never black is fine
only here I'm starting to get control
again and then here black has to go back
it's so nothing special probably he has
lots of resources here with the two
bishops and at the right moment taking
one of the Knights and so on the engine
only gives white a small a small edge so
and what game we also had this game was
a bit of a wacky opening seems g5 that
was only weakening a bit much I think
not yeah I should be better yeah okay
taking there good good
here see for taking this is a really
good school to get a good line by the
end
and the bishop f1 it's strategically
very strong and now now c4 is coming
next and black is without any decent
pawn diva at five
you know that's very good
I mean Asha I think I'm better here as
well
yeah the computer gives Weinstein edge
but it's not as good yeah there was one
funny moment um when I took a six and I
completely overlooked c5 which is the
cool news but I have not before that is
a good one but I didn't see it
beforehand and yeah this is more or less
winning but you have to be so cautious
yeah f6 of course wasn't great yeah what
was giving away the book so white is
winning here yeah I hope you enjoyed
this different format I was just too
late to join the tournament so I felt
okay what can I do when I try this out
now maybe I will just announce
assignment during my vacation time and
do this with the law somewhat longer
time control okay guys thanks for
watching